the president is pushing forward on
things that we know have broad-based
support and that we can immediately get
done call it the art of the possible the
president's plan to improve school
safety in the wake of the parkland
Florida shooting falls well short his
critics say of his own rhetoric now this
is not a popular thing to say in terms
of the NRA but I'm saying it anyway I'm
gonna just have to say it think of it
you can buy a handgun you can't buy one
then you have to wake you 21 but you can
buy the kind of weapon used in the
school shooting at 18 I think it's
something you have to think about what
the White House is thinking about is
studying raising the age to buy long
guns to 21 auditing the FBI tip line
establishing rigorous firearms training
for qualified teachers and expanding
mental health programs but no mention of
raising the age to buy weapons like the
ar-15 for example White House officials
call the plan a much-needed first step
we're looking at the best way forward to
push these other things through whether
it's on a state level whether it's on a
federal level the White House effort to
treat school safety the same way as
banks and airports will be studied by a
federal commission headed by Education
Secretary Betsy DeVos everything is on
the table and part of the job of this
commission will be to study that and see
if that is advanced ultimately as a
recommendation in next steps the
president said as much on Twitter noting
things are moving rapidly on this but
not much political support to put it
mildly but California congressman Adam
Schiff strongly disagreed tweeting
actually mr. president there's
overwhelming political support for gun
safety reform including age limits
universal background checks and an
assault weapon ban like you said too
many Republicans are scared of the NRA
including plainly you shift sarcastic
tweet part of a barrage of criticism
aimed at the president and the White
House for not doing more politics once
again meanwhile John the White House is
calling on States to pass so-called rpoS
those are those risk protection orders
what they do is they allow law
enforcement to remove the firearms from
individuals who previously demonstrated
they are a danger to themselves or
others
it would also keep them by the way from
purchasing
new firearms